[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і Британія
чудова, давайте дослідимо це ще раз, і
сьогодні ми збираємося поговорити про музику,
тому подивіться на це фото, і
насправді там є купа
слів  Тож, будь ласка, складіть
речення за допомогою цих слів,
давайте подивимося, що ми тут, у
Великобританії найкраща домашня музика світу, ніж у
Великобританії, інші слова добре,
тож давайте складати речення я
почну. Сполучене Королівство має найкращу
музику у світі чи  Сполучене Королівство
є домом для мільйонів музичних хіт-парадів,
тоді найкращі артисти відвідують найкращі
фестивалі, такі як Гластонбері, а потім
у Сполученому Королівстві проходить
музичний фестиваль номер один або щороку випускається 17 мільярдів записів,
тоді Oh Adele Adele —
моя улюблена співачка, а білборд — один
із  найвідоміші британські чарти, а
в Британії проводяться найкращі фестивалі, тому вдома
потренуйтеся складати речення, використовуючи
всі слова, і якщо ви можете зв’язати їх усі
в один текст або в одну історію,
то це буде чудово, давайте m
Ви можете сказати, де
були зроблені фотографії та що ви
бачите на знімках, щоб на знімках
ми бачимо натовпи людей, ми також
бачимо багато наметів та чудову англійську
сільську місцевість, і ми бачимо крокодила, а
може й ні  навіть один етап, але кілька
сцен або навіть більше, і насправді, хлопці,
як ви думаєте, що це один з
найбільших музичних фестивалів в Англії, і
він називається Glastonbury,
ми збираємося сьогодні поговорити про цей
фестиваль, якщо ви подивитесь, він називається
Glastonbury  Фестиваль сучасного
виконавського мистецтва, тож ви побачите там
не тільки музикантів, які грають, ви побачите
різні види розваг, але,
звичайно, головною визначною пам'яткою
для музикантів будуть головні сцени,
цікавим фактом є те, що музиканти
всіх видів і різної музики це
не має значення,
ветерани вони чи нові зірки, вони
можуть прийти і взяти участь у цьому
фестивалі минулого року у них було двадцять п’ять
сцен, і я навіть не злічити, як  багато
виконавців у них було, я б хотів, щоб я був там,
тому що вони були - мої улюблені групи,
вони грають The Chemical Brothers
і Біллі Айліш, тому сподіваюся, що
вони зіграють ще раз наступного року
урок читання,
і він буде довгим, тому,
будь ласка, приготуйтеся та наберіться терпіння, нам
потрібно знайти нового спонсора,
тож подивіться, у вас є їхній вступний
внесок, тітка Руті означає суму грошей,
яку ви повинні заплатити, щоб приєднатися до  Наприклад,
минулого року вступний внесок на фестиваль становив
майже чотириста фунтів стерлінгів, це
дорого, але гідно, а потім щорічно відбувається щорічно,
означає, що захід проводиться
щороку, тож, наприклад, Біллі
Айліш щорічно дає свої концерти в Лондоні,
а потім – інклюзивність, дуже
гарне слово і насправді  нова реальність у
нашому світі це якість ставитися до
всіх однаково, це означає, що ви
не реагуєте на чиїсь відмінності, але
ви ставитеся до всіх однаково, тоді приходить
гарне дієслово збігатися  e це означає відбуватися
одночасно, наприклад, на
фестивалі в Гластонбері було 25
етапів, і це означає, що всі
концерти співпали за часом, тоді настає
сонцестояння, сонцестояння, це дуже цікава
пора року,
це відбувається двічі, у нас є літо і
Зимове сонцестояння – це коли Сонце
досягає найвищої та найнижчої точки, тож те, що
відбувається в грудні, а інше
відбувається в червні, наступне слово – луг –
луг – це шматок лугу, потім
з’являється дуже цікавий прикметник
еклектичний еклектичний означає, що всі стилі
та ідеї змішуються та  використовувати разом
еклектичний може бути одягом еклектичний може бути
музикою еклектичним може бути фестивалем
фестиваль, який збирає всі стилі та всі
ідеї в один плавильний котел,
потім приходить невимушений невимушений означає
розслаблений і невимушений те, що
можна невимушено, можна створити атмосферу
-Назад
Мені б хотілося, щоб у наших школах була невимушена атмосфера,
але іноді ми повинні бути
дуже серйозними, а потім приходить Gate Crashers.
Ніхто не любить цих людей, вони ті,
хто приходить  e на вечірку чи подію
без запрошення
вони в основному ламають ворота та входять,
не будучи запрошеними, тоді все
закінчується переповненням натовпу велика
кількість людей і переповненням ще
більшої кількості людей багато людей,
тоді приходить добре, це наше  гумові
чоботи, і ви побачите, навіщо вам потрібні
чоботи на цьому фестивалі, а останнє
слово вимагати вимагати означає
дуже дорого добре, хлопці, перегляньте
ще раз усі слова, які вам знадобляться
під час читання тексту, тож давайте
продовжимо завдання читання, цього разу
буде  трохи інакше, ми звикли до
правдивих хибних відповідей, але цього разу у вас
буде M, це означає, що не згадується, це
означає, що такої інформації
в тексті немає, тому ви повинні прочитати
речення нижче та вирішити, чи
є вони правдивими, хибними чи ні  згадано,
давайте проглянемо ці речення, тому
перше речення фестиваль у Гластонбері
проходить у місті Гластонбері на
південному заході Англії, можливо, ми цього не
знаємо»  це називається фестивалем Гластонбері,
давайте перевіримо, тоді люди повернуться на
фестиваль через дружню
атмосферу, це може бути правдою, але
причини можуть бути різними, будь ласка, зверніть увагу
на це та перевірте докази
номер три, що фестиваль проводиться
до кінця цього літа.
кінець літа означає, можливо, серпень
останні дні серпня, і на фестивалі будуть виступати лише
відомі музиканти,
можливо, це модний фестиваль, і
тільки відомі музиканти виступають
там наступного в минулому, багато
людей знайшли способи отримати  на
фестиваль без квитка,
як можна потрапити на подію
без квитка, але, можливо, це правда,
організатори радять людям прийти добре
підготовленими до спекотної погоди, якщо
фестиваль відбувається влітку, то, можливо
, потрібно бути готовим до спекотної погоди  але
ми перевіримо в тексті наступні
спеціальні заходи, які зараз діють,
щоб люди не могли продавати квитки,
щоб заробити багато грошей, іноді
люди купують багато  квитки, а потім вони
перепродають їх, щоб отримати більше, ніж вони заплатили,
і це не дуже добре номер
вісім. Фестиваль підтримав кілька
благодійних організацій з моменту його початку в 1971 році, тому ми
повинні перевірити цю інформацію, а тепер наберіться
терпіння, і читання буде
довгим  тож приділіть всю свою увагу, і
якщо вам потрібно, і ви дивитеся нас на
YouTube, ви можете призупинити відео та прочитати
його ще раз, пам’ятайте, що
вам дозволено читати текст стільки
разів, скільки вам потрібно під час тесту, але у
вас є  щоб пам’ятати про обмеження часу
добре, давайте почнемо читати, тому
перший абзац і
давайте зануримося в Glastonbury Festival є
одним із найвідоміших музичних фестивалів
у світі, він був заснований фермером із Сомерсету
Майклом Івісом у 1971 році та
внесок на перший фестиваль  був
лише один фунт, що включало безкоштовне молоко
з ферми. Фестиваль проводиться
щорічно в маленькому селі Пілтон
на південному заході Англії та не
видно Гластонбері Тор.
не має багатьох міфів і легенд
і навіть вважається, що там був похований король Артур.
Гластонбері приваблює людей з
різних сфер життя, і одна з
причин, чому люди повертаються, — це
відчуття спільноти та інклюзивності,
яке асоціюється з фестивалем, який
зазвичай  відбувається в останні
вихідні червня, щоб збігтися з літнім
сонцестоянням у 1990-х роках, на південному лузі ферми було побудовано кам’яне коло,
яке вирівняно до Сонцестояння, музика
різноманітна, а великі зірки змішуються з новими
виконавцями, щоб сформувати еклектичний діапазон
Серед подій багато відомих артистів, зокрема
Oasis Coldplay Radiohead REM Manic
Street Preachers і The White Stripes
, виступали на фестивалі, який
Англійська національна опера навіть виступала в
2003 році, однак, хоча Гластонбері
найбільш відомий своєю музикою, є кілька
інших видів розваг.
включаючи театр комедійного танцю та
циркові вистави, навіть скелелазіння,
фестиваль має яскраву історію та
популярність продовжувала зростати протягом
багатьох років, незважаючи на невимушений дружній
Atmos
Glastonbury, часто стикався з
проблемами з гейткрашерами, які
досягли вершини в 2000 році, коли серйозна
переповненість була проблемою, 150 000
людей змогли увійти без квитків,
і це призвело до
організатори вирішили взяти річну перерву
у 2001 році, щоб дати собі час для того, щоб розібратися
з новими заходами безпеки та внести деякі
організаційні покращення. Зовнішня
компанія, мінімальна організація-скрипач,
тепер піклується про безпеку на заході,
погода не завжди була прихильною до
відвідувачів фестивалю в 2005 році  але грози
призвели до того, що багато ділянок майданчика були
затоплені, а деякі етапи навіть були
вражені блискавкою. Загальна порада
відвідувачам – взяти з собою гарні
штани та водонепроникну куртку та
бути готовим до великих черг до
туалетів у 2007 році.  квитки заробили 145 фунтів стерлінгів
за всі три дні і були розпродані лише за
годину 45 хвилин, щоб подолати
проблему сумок b  Використовуючи велику кількість
квитків і обдираючи людей,
продаючи їх за здирницькі ціни
на таких веб-сайтах, як eBay, відвідувачі
тепер повинні пройти процедуру попередньої реєстрації, яка
передбачає надання певної
особистої інформації та фотографії паспортного
розміру, частина прибутку від
фестивалю зазвичай жертвується  на благодійність
і такі організації, як C і D, Oxfam
і Greenpeace мали всі переваги в
минулому, натомість
Oxfam допоміг організованим волонтерам
працювати на фестивалі, яке довге завдання
ми маємо,
добре, хлопці, якщо вам потрібно
прочитати ще раз, і ви»  дивлячись на нас
на YouTube, ви можете зробити це, просто зупиніть
відео та прочитайте реферат, який вам потрібно
прочитати ще раз, тепер давайте повернемося до
завдання, тому я ще раз маю нагадати вам,
що цього разу речення там не
лише правдиві чи хибні  це також
речення, яке не згадується, тому
інформація, яка не була згадана
в тексті, добре, тому перегляньте ще
раз весь спектр питань, а
потім почнемо робити  завдання добре, хлопці, тож
давайте подивимося, що фестиваль Lessenberry проводиться
в місті Гластонбері на
південному заході Англії, це твердження є
помилковим, хоча його називають
фестивалем Гластонбері, але він проводиться щорічно в
маленькому селі Пілтон на південному
заході Англії та
Гластонбері Тор не помічається, але не в місті
Гластонбері ок наступне твердження
наступне твердження правдиве люди повернулися
на фестиваль через дружню
атмосферу, і в тексті ми маємо
синоніми до цієї фрази, у
тексті зазначено, що Гластонбері  приваблює
людей з різних сфер життя,
і одна з причин, чому люди
повертаються, - це почуття спільноти та
інклюзивності, тому, коли у вас є
почуття спільноти та
серйозні ключі, це означало, що вас
оточують друзі та
загальна атмосфера  дружелюбно наступне
твердження, що фестиваль проводиться
наприкінці літа,
можливо, ви потрапили на цей відволікаючий фактор, який
зазвичай проходить на фестивалі  відбувається в
останні вихідні червня, але насправді
останні вихідні червня - це не
кінець літа, тому твердження є хибним
наступне твердження, що на фестивалі виступають лише відомі музиканти,
твердження є
хибним, тому що музика різноманітна і
велика  зірки змішуються з новими виконавцями, щоб утворити
еклектичне коло подій чи пам'ятаєте ви
це слово еклектика різні
ідеї різні стилі разом в одному
плавильному котлі добре готові до наступного
речення ось воно, і це правда, тому
в минулому багато людей знаходили способи
отримати  на фестиваль без квитка,
чи пам’ятаєте ви слово зі
словникового запасу Gatecrasher,
тож Gatecrasher – це той, хто потрапляє
на вашу подію або вашу вечірку
без запрошення, і це сталося з
фестивалем Glastonbury, цифри
надзвичайні, вони дійсно величезні, наприклад,
150 000  людям вдалося потрапити без
квитків, я не можу уявити, що така кількість
людей прийде на фестиваль,
який для нас є містом, добре, так що  оскільки
номер шостий, і це неправда,
організатори радять людям приходити добре
підготовленими до спекотної погоди, хоча це
буває влітку, але ви знаєте, що
клімат Великобританії відрізняється
від нашого, і влітку може бути дійсно дощ,
і загальна порада для тих
хто прийде на фестиваль, має взяти з собою
хороші штани та водонепроникну
куртку, щоб бути готовим до довгих
черг до туалетів, тому
що було б багато дощів, а колись
навіть весь фестиваль був затоплений,
номер сім, і це правда
Зараз діють спеціальні заходи, щоб
люди не могли самостійно продавати квитки,
щоб правильно заробити, і відвідувачі
тепер повинні пройти процес попередньої реєстрації,
щоб організатори були
впевнені, що це ви купили
квиток і це ви  збирається
приїхати на фестиваль і що ви не
збираєтеся перепродавати цей квиток за дуже
дорогою ціною, а останній, який ви бачите,
має інший колір, це означає, що
ця інформація  не згадується
в тексті, у заяві говориться, що
фестиваль підтримав кілька благодійних організацій з моменту його
початку в 1971 році, справжня правда полягає в тому, що
насправді фестиваль розпочався в 1971 році,
але в тексті не зазначено, що він
почав підтримувати кілька благодійних організацій
з самого початку, тому ви  можна детально прочитати,
що частина прибутків від
фестивалю зазвичай передається на благодійність
та організаціям, таким як Oxfam тощо
, але в тексті не вказано, що
вони започаткували цю традицію в 1971 році, тому,
хлопці, у нас це вперше таке
Незгадане твердження в тексті,
зверніть увагу на деякі з ваших доповідей, які ви можете мати
під час зовнішнього оцінювання або
під час інших тестів з англійської мови, які ви
збираєтеся складати, може бути
таке завдання, добре, хлопці, як ви задавали мені
багато запитань  в Instagram про фразові
дієслова та найкращий спосіб їх вивчити
. Найкращий спосіб вивчити їх – це, звичайно,
просто навчитися складати речення за допомогою
Quizlet, створювати свої картки та,
звичайно, практику  ce в цьому тексті було
багато фразових дієслів, давайте переглянемо
деякі з них,
щоб вони були налаштовані повертатися
шукали притягувати в доглядати після lit
знову зірвати ви можете призупинити це відео
і спробувати знайти всі ці фразові дієслова
в тексті це допоможе вам зрозуміти
сенс, але цього разу я допоможу вам,
і я маю визначення, тому
встановити щось означає,
наприклад, створити бізнес, або ви
можете організувати фестиваль, а потім  результат у
означає привести до вашого
результату привести до результатів привести лідера і це означає
призвести до наступного, щоб стягнути
надмірну суму або отримати гроші несправедливо.
багато, але це несправедливо, тоді потрібно
ввести, щоб відповісти дуже легко отримати
в цьому, щоб допомогти вам
зрозуміти, що ви повинні щось ввести,
тому наступний, щоб подбати
про це, означає подбати, наприклад,
я  Я доглядаю за своєю молодшою сестрою, я бе
у  g піклування про неї потім приходить, щоб
організувати чи вирішити щось, це означає
вирішити це добре, давайте
вирішимо цю проблему, давайте вирішимо її наступне, щоб
повернутися або відвідати щось кудись це
означає повернутися ви пам'ятаєте, що люди
повертаються на фестиваль, тому  вони
знову відвідують
фестиваль, вони повернулися на цей фестиваль,
і останній з них - залучити та
залучити когось до
чогось, це означає залучити, щоб це могло
привернути вашу увагу, ви можете бути залучені
до чогось добре, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що ви
дійсно використовуєте Quizlet і  Я сподіваюся, що
ви складете список фразових дієслів,
які допоможуть вам разом із лексикою,
яку ви мали на початку уроку,
тепер хлопці, ваше домашнє завдання, ви повинні
організувати свій власний літній фестиваль, будь ласка,
скористайтеся наведеними нижче запитаннями як посібником, щоб
допомогти  ви плануєте свій літній фестиваль, тож
де швидше пройде як
ви будете називати вас перш за все скільки
це триватиме яка розвага
яка буде
музика яка буде  тут буде кемпінг, чи
будуть люди їсти чи пити, які
у вас там зручності, скільки
це буде коштувати і як ви будете рекламувати
свій фестиваль і чи пожертвуєте ви
частину прибутку на благодійність, тож якщо ви
відповісте на всі ці запитання навіть за два
або три речення ви матимете дуже
гарну промову про свій фестиваль, якщо ви
додасте презентацію, тоді це буде
дуже гарний проект для виконання, і щоб спланувати свій
літній фестиваль, ви повинні пам'ятати,
що всі ваші мрії можуть здійснитися,
ви найбільший мрійник  у вашому житті і
будьте впевнені, що одного разу всі ваші
мрії можуть здійснитися, а бонусом
є гра Kahoot, яку я створив, і я
поділюся з вами посиланням, щоб ви могли
грати зі своїми друзями,
це про британську музику, добре, хлопці, британці
музика, це дуже цікаво, і це не
тільки про Beatles
або Queen, слухайте її, насолоджуйтеся нею та слідкуйте за
оновленнями
[Музика]
ви